- Only thing it is,
man, I had a rough life.
I lived in the neighborhood where
there was no pity for the weak.
You couldn't smile at 'em,
you didn't have no sympathy,
you didn't have no remorse.
If he got in the way, and
he did the wrong thing,
you broke his ass off and
you left him where he at.
Ain't no going back to
clean him up, you know?
If he bleeding and shit, you know?
I had a homie that was
kickin' it with me over here
in the neighborhood, and he hit the dude
in the face with a bottle.
And, man, do you know what it feels like
to get hit in the face
with a glass, glass bottle?
And then the skin just tear?
And you lookin' at him
like, what do you do?
And these motherfuckers right here,
I gotta roll with them,
because if I don't roll
with them, I'ma be one of them dudes
gettin' hit with the fucking bottle, too.
So, I don't want that, I'd
rather just say fuck it,
I'm riding with y'all.
Shit, peer pressure is a mug, you know?
And when you don't have
nobody with you, dog,
that's just the way it is, you know?
I mean, I coulda asked the homie,
dog, why you doin' some shit like that?
That nigga probably woulda
jumped in my ass, man.
So, I ain't trippin'.
But you got people that,
I got some little homies, man,
they did a little drive by, right?
I'm sitting in the county jail,
I'm in here for robbery right now,
and he come in for a drive by.
I said, dog, what happened?
He said, "Man, we went over one, dog,
"we went and did our thing".
I say, nigga, I heard
you was drunk, nigga,
and the police chased y'all,
and y'all ran the car
up a pole or something
Nigga, what happened?
He said, "Hey, dog, we
busted on these niggas,
"and the police were
comin' around the corner
"as we was bustin', and that's how they
"got up on us and stuff.
"And so I tried to punch it and shit,
"and I tried to punch it all the way
"back to the hood and stuff, and I ran."
I said, man, so, did you shoot the dude?
You know where he shot the dude at?
He shot the dude in the damn leg.
Do you get recognition for that?
Do you pat a nigga on the back for that?
They was like, "Damn, dog,
where'd you shoot him at?"
"I shot him in the leg."
You know, "What kind of gun you had?"
"A .380."
You had a small gun,
small bullets, small car.
Not enough gas to get
away from them one time,
so you got caught.
So, is the dude coming to court?
Hell, yeah, he comin' to
court to testify against him.
And make it so cold,
you believe me or not,
usually when you shot a
person above the waist
is when you really get some time.
They gave my little homie life
for shootin' that motherfucker in the leg.
I'da got my motherfuckin' ass
out of that motherfuckin' car,
walked up, and knocked that nigga down.
That's how you, if you're
gonna go do some dumb shit.
You know, but somewhere along the line,
somebody gotta be the smart man
and wake up and recognize reality
and know what's real, man.
I got another homie, let me tell you,
that thought they was goin'
up, goin' to do a drive-by,
and they went in this apartment building
and threw a bunch of
bombs in these apartments,
and blew up kids.
And instead of them
gettin' the death penalty,
they took the life without,
with no possibility of parole.
So, the neighborhood I come from,
it's always been a tough
neighborhood to live in.
And it's just not the neighborhood itself,
it's the peoples.
'Cause the neighborhood don't make it bad,
it's the peoples that's
there that make it bad.
And, Hell, I done been
placed in positions where,
"Man, go get the gun, dog.
"We fi'n' to go do somethin'."
And if I, man, I don't
wanna roll with that,
"Nigga, what you mean you don't
wanna roll with that, nigga?
"Nigga, you rollin', nigga!
"You ain't down with us in this stuff?"
No, man.
What, you tell a motherfucka I'm sick?
I got the flu, man, I can't go right now.
"Nigga, you better get
your ass on out here, man.
"Come on."
All right, dog, I got you,
I got you, I'm comin'.
So, when you up against shit like that,
and peoples that ain't been up in,
a lot of these dudes
down here you see now,
they come from nice homes,
nice family, good background,
firm education that help
'em get certain things
that they needed in order
to go to the next step
of college or whatever, you know?
I didn't get that chance, dog.
Because we didn't have
enough to push ahead.
Maybe I shoulda been smart
enough when I got a little older.
But I was already incarcerated,
and I was already
adapted to the negativity
that makes you a bad person in society.
I don't wanna call myself
any bad person now,
because I think that
everybody deserves a chance
to see what's real and what's not real.
And, if I can go back and
turn the hands of time,
I would do the right thing.
Because I know it's a lot
more opportunities out there,
and a lot more things
that coulda happened,
that could have been in my
favor where I coulda did better,
and where I coulda had my own home,
maybe even a little small business.
I don't know, but I coulda had a lot more
laid in my position if
I'da took the time out,
stayed in school, and
listened to my mother.
But, some of the bad things that I learned
was pushed from my mother,
because she was, like,
"Why you hangin' around these little boys?
"Why don't you go around with
some peoples older your age?"
I told her that, shit,
the niggas that's my age,
they gangs and stuff,
they were with gangs.
And so she was, like,
"Well, why don't you hang
"with Eric and Michael now?"
Shit, I did.
When we went to school,
we was at the school,
and them niggas left, and
niggas come up to school
and take our shit.
I ain't gonna be with
no niggas that's scared.
I wanna be with somebody that ain't
gonna take nobody's bullshit.
So, that's why I made the
decisions the way I made 'em.
It was wrong, and I couldn't
show it in my mother's eyes
because she only wanted
the best things for me.
But she didn't know
what I had to deal with
when it was time to go to school,
when it was time to walk the streets,
when it was time to hang out.
She didn't know nothin' about that,
'cause she was too busy
sittin' in the house, drinkin',
or doin' her own thing.
So, I made my decisions for myself.
And I had three younger brothers
that was younger than me
that I needed to show support to.
So, if they had problems,
I wanted to let them know to come get me,
and I'll stand up for you, dog.
I'll fight for you.
And I remember my little
brother, plain as day,
he had a problem one day with a dude,
and he come get me, sayin', "Hey, SB,
"this nigga over here
trippin' on me and stuff."
And I said, I got you.
Come on, let's go right here,
let this nigga know right now, nigga,
not to, you know, mess
with you anymore, nigga.
And I went around there,
and he came and got his brothers,
he went and got his brothers
to do it up for the fight.
And I went and got my brothers,
and I told him, look, however we do it,
it's still gonna be cool.
I knocked that nigga out.
My little brother, he was happy.
But it made us move, now, to where
we thought we was hardcores now, you know?
I mean, thinkin' again,
I just wanna say, man,
after seein' all the things I did in life,
I would want somethin' better than
what I lived on that stage right there.
'Cause it didn't get me nothin'.
Now, I'm up in age, and I have nothin'.
I'm just tryin' to be peaceful now.
I still carry the gang
activities when it's necessary,
and I'm a gang affiliated.
Because I come from an area
where that's all I knew.
That's all I know.
That's all I stand by.
That's all I'll take to my grave.
It is what it is.
I won't count the number,
I just roll with it.